everyone on YouTube knows me as a nice
guy I'm practically the nicest guy on
the entire planet not to brag or
anything but I am a such a nice guy when
women reject me I do not reach for my AR
I reach for my fedora I respect you I
respect you too damn much please live a
full life without me
that's how nice of a guy I am but what I
respect even more than nice guys such as
myself by the way is of course nice
girls that's right girls can be nice too
so let's go through some examples of
nice girls because I just respect you
too damn much not to because guys aren't
allowed to find women attractive my
girlfriend told me she would suck John
Mayer's peepee in front of her own dad
because she loves him so much same I
said the girl on Netflix showed we were
watching was cute see she is being nice
here she's like she's stepping aside
realizing when she stepped over boundary
oh you like this girl I will step aside
enjoy yourself have a good time my wife
gets when I have Piper as companion oh
yeah we can meet up and go through the
project it looks easy enough we can
finish quick wow this seems like a great
time you know a boy and a whamon just
working on their science project
together okay
just don't try anything you were talking
about your girl last class and I don't
want to interfere with that I've been
the other woman before and I don't want
to ever ever do that again I don't want
to ever redo that I saw you staring at
me last class and I don't think you
should be going we do in that if you
have
you brought three honey buns to class I
was staring cuz I thought you'd offer
what you didn't by the way she's clearly
just making sure of this versus diet
what a nice girl
those damn unattractive people staying
in loving relationship
I get really depressed when ugly people
get lasting relationships and I can't
find a single decent boy it's tough
being a nice girl how dare they how dare
they
my boyfriend set 4 hours playing this
and ignoring me so I fixed his little
issue
it's basically abuse to pick a game over
your girl come on that's full at 4 she's
practically doing him a favor here are
you huh yes babe take a picture of its
spoon on top of your head why to prove
you're home okay wait
hmm what you could have taken that
yesterday food you never know see this
is what I'm talking about
a whamon a real web presses everything
it isn't just she doesn't just buy into
anything that the man or anyone says she
doesn't fall for the lives of the media
and boyfriends she's too woke for that
why don't you add a timestamp everyone
knows
you need to incur a but I'm stamping the
spoon that you put on top of your head
this is really the fault of the man here
and I completely agree with the women as
I do always this is how to solve an
argument with the women to flowchart mr.
Weyman wrong yes ramen is never wrong
mr. Weyman wrong no women is never wrong
that's right everybody
women is never with the women murder
someone
mr. women wrong women is never wrong the
women carpet strike your videos wherever
it is never wrong because saying how you
actually feel in a healthy manner is so
overrated if I throw a fit and tell you
to leave please don't leave because I
will be over in like three minutes okay
hang in there baby this reminds me of
13th reasons why have you guys seen that
or is it 12 reasons why I don't remember
there's this one scene where the main
character basically tells the guy leave
just go and he goes no no I really want
to stay with you please like don't tell
me to leave babe just leave me please
oh god okay fine I will leave why did
you leave me I'm not even making fun of
it it's exams for beta I know I'm
pushing this me pretty hard like I don't
we're just having fun here guys okay
please we are respecting women here on
this channel no funny business
Waymon always right
all women are a queen can we get in the
comments everybody so that it doesn't
get miss misunderstood by random
articles that will pick one comment out
of context and be like this is what
people think out of this video we found
one comment saying this what do boys
even find attractive about boobs they're
literally a ball of fat on a girl's
chest like if you can love me for the
fat on my chest why can't you love me
for the fat on my stomach
[Music]
why don't you love all my fatty lumps
huh you only care about the two fell in
love with the boob meter come from why
do women find air respectable man why
don't why can't they appreciate the hair
on my butt to swell hey I hope you don't
mind me asking who this is
we met at Snoopy's incest our last week
you don't remember I met a lot of people
there so no sorry mind if I ask how you
got my number I overheard you give it to
the dude you were learning with I gave
it to him since the ass not okay to do
that sorry I think I'm done here why not
it's harmless though but we could get to
know each other sorry but I don't even
know who this is and I'm a bit
uncomfortable with this it's narrow me
my bad I didn't say it earlier sorry
it's super gonna be there on Friday
right
Jesus Christ I didn't realize girls were
equally psychopathic as boys this has
really changed him this has changed my
perspective on a lot of things honestly
I hate online dating websites when I ask
a man how tall he is and he asked me how
much I weigh back it's a sign of
immaturity let me break this down every
human is different and we all come in a
unique shapes and sizes but as long as
you ask me what my unique shape and size
is and I agree also of course I don't
know how to read American measurement
five six in China you are still five six
in the US that measurement is solid and
looks the same all over the world I am
over 200 pounds weight how much is that
Tony why you know me if she's a
weightlifter that's pretty impressive
but I carry my weight she is a
weightlifter like a damn Queen but
someone taller or shorter than me with
the same weight is gonna look different
from me so when I ask how tall a guy is
I'm trying to see on the most basic
fundamental level if I'm going to be
attracted to you my number on my scale
is not going to change anything about me
I love how she's so aware she's so
self-aware that's what I love about
women like this one it really makes you
think oh this is the original is this
the original of the meme that everyone
keeps posting why can't I find a guy
like hey no I'm literally been a guy in
the pic I would saw what the original
was that's hilarious
this proves that women doesn't really
want anyone me I'm so happy in this
relationship also me plant a hair tie in
his bed pretend it's not yours blame it
on another girl and start a fight Jesus
Christ this reminds me of that bag clip
promised me we would have two kids and
now he doesn't want any more my friend I
think I should trick him and stop taking
my birth control
what do you think Wendy yeah what do you
what do you think when embarrassed to
say this because I don't like spousal
lying however men have never been in
control of our bodies we're the ones in
control I'm not going to suggest that
you do that but look into my eyes and
I'm not gonna tell you to stop using
birth control without telling your mom
and make a conceive a child without the
other person's consent but am I gonna
are you a nice girl as well do let me
know because I will tip my fedora to you
leave it like if you're a nice girl and
leave a night like if you're a nice guy
and leave it like if you're just nice in
general fedora tip and as always good
good have a great day
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]